[Music]
nobody expects you to be Bill Mitchell
overnight the most important thing to
remember is this general presence
presence right now whenever he stands at
a podium president Mitchell always has
one hand in the pocket of his coat
that's at a press conference otherwise
they're almost always on the podium you
know I'm not certain about that oh yeah
I don't remember the convention speech
in America stronger than the one we were
given in America prouder than the one we
found right there on the podium
except on America winning point that's a
scene from the 1993 comedy Dave about a
man who finds himself impersonating the
President
now the oscar-nominated movie is being
staged in Washington as a live-action
musical ed O'Keefe joins us with more
Edie hail to the chief he's the one we
all say hailed a good night play the new
musical about a guy who never thought
he'd run the country has nothing to do
with President Trump but producers
expect their show might help audiences
escape from the rough and tumble of
real-life politics in Washington Dave is
based on a simple premise anybody in
America can become president and here's
what might happen if they did the movie
debuted in 1993 just get rid of the grin
you look like a schmuck Kevin Kline is
that unsuspecting schmuck who happens to
look a lot like the president he's asked
to be a secret standing but when the
real commander-in-chief has a stroke
Dave gets stuck in the job is this legal
oh yeah probably maybe it's not legal
per se
now Dave sings about his presidential
predicament musical retelling the movie
debuted in Washington this week
introducing the phony but well-meaning
executive to a new generation I'm very
excited because this is the first time
I've interviewed a president and the
first lady together oh my gosh we're
here to please Drew Geylang and Mamie
Paris star as Dave and the real first
lady in the production that debuted at
Washington's Arena Stage how many times
did you watch the movie I've seen the
movie tons of times but since we've been
rehearsing this big goose egg none I
don't know that I remember the first
time I saw the movie but I've definitely
seen the movie plenty as they prepared
to play a president and first lady both
actors said they took inspiration from a
wide range of White House residents
I'm going full Millard Fillmore Zachary
Tyler you know I like to go for the you
know the really really forgettable
president absolutely go for it yeah yeah
that's what everybody wants to see but
you don't go home at night and watch the
news and go oh maybe I should try a
little bit of that there's a lot of isms
that are inherent in in politics there's
a lot of there's a lot of very specific
hand movements that get used by everyone
this guy does this thing and or this guy
likes to really gesture with his full
hand and sometimes it's two fingers and
sometimes it's like the chopped like
sawed the side chop producers have been
working to bring Dave to the stage for
more than four years long before the
2016 campaign but after the election of
Donald Trump director Tina Landau says
the feel-good story took on a deeper
meaning the piece became more necessary
we've very purposely tried to keep it
timeless but in doing so we have found
that it remains timely every day in new
ways
when a audience member walks out of the
show what do you want them to do in
response to the play vote vote that's
what I that's what we hope for I feel
like the show is a lot about
participation and its participation in
our politics and also in our personal
relationships Washington is a fitting
place for Landau's show to open after
all
the real White House is just two miles
up the road the city is along history as
an early proving ground for big-budget
shows from classics like West Side Story
and Hello Dolly to new hits like Mean
Girls and dear Evan Hanson the goal is
that eventually Dave and his singing
staffers will make it to Broadway but
giling says he hopes the show's message
that one man can make a difference
first resonates in the nation's capital
everybody that lives in works in
Washington DC especially no one came
here to be a part of a problem everyone
came here to fix something or were sent
here to fix something and and I think
the altruism inherent in that is
something that that Dave is about the
message is silver-screen counterpart
would seem to endorse you make it nice
president Dave Kovac
[Music]
this show runs through August 19th and
we should point out that Tina Landau the
director no stranger to Broadway hits
just before heading to Washington to
direct Dave she was the director of
Spongebob Squarepants the musical which
of course is filling seats here on
Broadway now a good example of another
hit being adapted from TV and movies we
love Dave I want to know the shower
scene and the big fish scene yeah you
get this before the end of the of the
play I will admit I have not seen it in
full I will this week so I will report
back ok please that movie tonight thank
you